hello world
it's time for a thought experiment
let's imagine the cold war went another
way
after the nazis surrendered
[Music]
the soviet union flexed its muscles and
asserted its imperial might
from tokyo to tacoma
[Music]
memorials to the fatherland popped up
around the globe
this would be the washington monument
this could have been your morning
commute
[Music]
and now let's fast forward these were
the first semiconductors
this is your keyboard this was the first
ibm computer
this is facebook headquarters this
is silicon valley well
that didn't happen but in modern russia
it's easy to get confused with an extra
helping of spycraft
technology here developed a world apart
from silicon valley
and that didn't change when the soviet
union collapsed
25 years later russia has copied large
parts of the web
the rest of us know and love they built
a russian internet and with new laws
cooked up by the kremlin
and rubber stamped in moscow more and
more
it's a sovereign internet like anything
sovereign
it needs walls to protect it and virtual
walls are going up today
to find out exactly how the russian web
works
there was only one thing to do
i had to upload myself
[Applause]
now that i'm inside i'll meet a tech
oligarch
[Applause]
travel to siberia to dive into a
surprising
and very remote startup scene
and chase the ever elusive russian
hacker
using the machine learning you could
create a technology
which helped to predict a crime let's
enter this parallel universe together
on this episode of hello world
silicon valley may be home to some of
the biggest tech giants in the world
but it's being challenged like never
before
crazy tech geniuses have popped up all
over the planet
making things that will blow your mind
my name is ashley vance i'm an author
and journalist
and i'm on a quest to find the most
innovative tech creations
and meet the beautiful freaks behind
them
in moscow over the past decade the
tsar's gilded churches and monuments to
the proletariat
have given way to the symbols of modern
russia
opulent capitalist towers that poke
through the clouds
at the heart of this is where i met
dimitri grisham hello domitri
he's the co-founder of mailroo group and
one of only a few people
east of helsinki who can drive me to the
office in his own tesla
i organized the drive for all my
employees like
3 000 people because they want all to
test how accelerate
dimitri sits atop a russian tech empire
and runs an investment fund for robotics
with its roots in silicon valley
that doesn't make you want to move there
you have so much going on here
maybe one day never say never right
overall then do you consider the russian
taxi in competitive
yes and you know it's interesting things
that it's very few countries where
local players are very strong and
comparing for example with china this
internet is fully closed we have
facebook instagram
all kind of western players and still uh
pretty successful so i think we have
pretty
pretty tough competition why are russian
engineers so good
i think it's type of education in russia
still like mathematics and anything
around engineering they give you very
broad view so if you want to be very
creative
in technology this is i think very good
education
this is the guy charging station here
okay so everybody knows when you're in
the office yeah
[Music]
dimitri's tried to copy silicon valley
culture here in moscow where male root
group operates two instant messaging
networks
a search engine a price comparison
website
and a ton of online games
they also control the three largest
russian social networking sites
the biggest one is vk the facebook
knockoff
dimitri and mail root group took over vk
in 2014
after its founder pavel durov refused to
reveal information about ukrainian
activists to the kremlin
durov lost his company and now lives in
self-imposed exile
dimitri is also one of the world's
biggest investors in robotics
he put a hundred million dollars into
american firms that produce some
familiar faces
what's been the biggest hit of all your
robotics companies so
i like all my investments i can say
[Music]
definitely i like bb-8 a lot
they also zipline who do drones
long-range delivery
and now they start to do blood delivery
in rwanda
[Music]
dimitri ships all kinds of nerd gear to
moscow
to try it out and see if he wants to
invest
what's the point of the game we should
kill robots
that's so good for you as someone who
puts
all this money into robots aren't you oh
it's really cool
[Music]
to get a taste of the high life of a
tech oligarch
[Music]
dimitri and i headed for a bite to eat
at the tallest restaurant in europe
354 meters above the moscow traffic
tell me a little bit about your family
history so well yeah i have pretty
pretty much engineering
family and i was born in city called
kapustiniar1
[Music]
kapustin yar was the soviet union's
answer to area 51.
a top-secret city where rocket
scientists like dimitri's grandfather
tested ballistic missiles and rockets
during the space race
dimitri grew up programming on computers
that plugged into soviet tvs
but things really took off when he
enrolled at moscow state technical
university
in 1995. and the same year
microsoft announced windows 95 this
famous song from rolling stone started
me up
next two years i try to write my own
windows
it's so expensive windows maybe you can
just cheap cheap version
so sitting writing it but after some
time
i say uh okay no it's too hard
[Music]
he might have failed to rewrite the
world's most popular operating system
but he did stumble on the copycat
business model
that became mailroo group and at the
height of the 2001 tech crash
he had to find a way to keep the new
company alive
with no cash i became the ceo of the
company
and my idea was like let's try to
survive no matter
how we try to do a lot of tricks for
example
by coming with my car it was a ladder
russian russian car we put several
servers like physically
and move them to more cheaper data
center
[Music]
it's hard to imagine now but in 2004
only 9 of russians had internet access
what was the russian government's
assessment of the technology
industry they didn't know that they
exist
that all changed in 2012.
russia had become the biggest internet
market in europe
some people use the web to complain
about putin
and organize protests against his
reelection
the kremlin responded in full orwellian
glory
with a series of laws that allows them
to flag opposition
sites as extremists and blacklist them
ever since it's been hard to tell where
the vlad web begins
and ends i think in the us the idea
is that the russian government and the
tech companies are just
intertwined and the if the government
wants to read people's emails whatever
they want to do
they're going to let them do that if you
follow the law you're okay
definitely the laws became more
complicated right and sometimes it's
definitely the way how to interpret the
law if you have right now laws that
government can shut down any service
which is uh
not hosting the service inside of russia
they can
there's law definitely you can have big
discussion
as this law is good or bad but this only
way how to
you can operate
those new laws passed this year would
make edward snowden weep into his bush
they demand all sites russians can
access move their servers here
including the googles and facebooks of
the world
once on russian soil they have to store
six months worth of data
about people's every move online and
then give the kremlin access
russian companies like melrou protested
they said these measures would take a
ridiculous amount of storage space
but they obviously lost american
companies have said there's no way
they're moving to russia
so now their criminal enterprises here
and that's how you build a sovereign
internet
when we grow our business our concept
was that
internet was a global system no border
at all
users everywhere can connect to
everywhere data can be immigrating
everything so it's really was global
phenomena
but now i think that fundamental global
shift everywhere
that you have country you have borders
and inside these borders you have
different kind of rules
how data is moving how connectivity is
moving who can connect to what
who can do what so
we're not having like global internet we
have some kind of some
global internet but a lot of like local
internets
and for me this is big set in terms of
change
just a couple of weeks after we visited
dimitri he stepped down as ceo of mailru
the government approved ceo vk is taking
his place
the new guy also happens to be the son
of the head of russia's largest
state-run
television channel
[Music]
coming up next it's off to siberia where
the russian government
is trying to build a tech utopia in the
taiga
this is useful in order to make plasma
thrusters
for space ships
to find out how russia makes tech magic
happen
all you have to do is hop on a flight
from moscow to siberia
yes that's siberia it's not just for
gulags anymore
it's hard to wrap your head around just
how big siberia
is and even harder to understand how
most people live here
so to get acquainted i found another
dimitri
this one a real natural-born siberian
man
to initiate me into the ways of the
russian wilderness
i'm sure this is a good idea right
perfect idea
a trip to the banya is an ancient and
some would say masochistic
russian bonding ritual it consists of
three delightful steps
okay ashley inferno is ready for
entrance
step one nearly have heat stroke
[Music]
step two shrinkage
step three get whacked
what does this do keep silent please
when he's not beating other men with
birch branches my new russian friend
dimitri
is a philosophy professor here in
academic
that's my destination a small town hours
by plane from moscow
and about 30 minutes outside russia's
third largest city
novosibirsk
nikita khrushchev's government declared
60 years ago
that this would be the siberian home of
the soviet academy of sciences
built from nothing in the middle of a
remote tiger forest
that stretches halfway around the planet
academic it was the first soviet
technopolis
and it was a good opportunity for many
young scientists
how has it changed over the last 40
years in comparison to soviet time
we have not so much opportunities
but we love our place because it's
wonderful
40 institutes a real scientific
community
show toast
well we'll test here no beauty to the
enemies of
science cheers
[Music]
soaked swatted steaming and having
proven my loyalty to science
i was ready to explore akadem goradak
[Music]
here the soviets hid temples to science
in the trees
with shrines to match like this one
to all the mice they sacrificed on the
altar of genetic research
[Music]
inside the nuclear physics institute it
feels like i walked under the set of dr
strangelove
these analog dials laser contraptions
and miles of metal pipes were all built
to push nuclear science to its summit
replicating the sun's power by smashing
atoms together
people have been chasing fusion for
decades
what's still encouraging and exciting
about this field the scientific problem
is like a huge mountain
and for 60 years people are trying to
get to the top
everything around the base of the
mountain is like a
trash dump bodies and stuff
but you can imagine the results you can
achieve when you get to the top
professor alexei beklumichev researches
something called
open trap mechanisms to encourage fusion
in theory it's a shortcut to the top of
the mountain
with a smaller load this is also useful
in order to make
plasma thrusters for space ships
so you could use this to power a
spaceship going to mars
yeah at the moment it is just an idea
it needs a lot of refinement so this is
more of like a 2080
sort of thing yeah
the soviet government attracted
brilliant minds like alexeis to siberia
with spacious apartments in the kind of
prestige they could only get
in a town founded as a utopian
nerdocracy
but when the soviet union fell so did
the walls keeping scientists here
and many of them bolted to work at ibm
or mit
or boeing for those who stayed
the utopia has lost its luster
over time the difference in pay
between scientists and say bus drivers
went in favor of bus drivers
if you are overworked and without pay
you want to go
elsewhere
ten years ago the russian government
decided it needed to hit refresh on the
entire town
to pull siberian science out of its
post-soviet slump
they're turning to a new generation of
engineers
plucked from the taiga to lead the way
and one of the most successful so far is
dimitri tribitsin
yes another dimitri today akadem gardok
is changing now there are not only
scientists but
there are also a lot of companies more
like startups
yeah more like startups dimitri's
company theon
started off making king size air filters
for hospitals
and other businesses as far as starting
a company here you didn't think
now that i have this idea i'm going to
run off to silicon valley
you decided this was the spot where you
would give it a go
well it's very comfortable place and
there are a lot of
good smart people here also have very
fresh air
here and it's very useful yeah it's very
useful for our company because we can
we can compare the air we produce with
the
cleanest air in the world
today dimitri is the poster boy for a
siberian startup success story
and he feels like he's close to the
finish line on phase one of his vision
phase two takes him to china where his
company is rapidly expanding
there he hopes to get his devices out of
hospitals
and into homes with this little guy that
detects pollutants in the air
you just blow over the top it doesn't
matter like co2
that's enough look it goes down so the
lights are going down yeah
it means that air quality is not very
good
now it tried to increase the speed of
fan in breezer in this room to lower the
concentration of carbon dioxide
cool it seems to work
dimitri is not a holy self-made man
teon's success belongs to him but it's
built on a blueprint drawn up by the
russian government
his headquarters is on a sprawling
government-funded campus
called academ park with this crazy tower
in the middle of it
not recommended if you have a fear of
heights
this place is a prime example of one of
the big ideas in russian tech
a cradle cradle-to-grave genius factory
[Music]
across the country they start them young
with a strictly uniform education
heavy on math and science they pull the
best out of siberia and send them down
the street to nova sabirsk state
university
from there they used to funnel their
brains to places like the nuclear
institute
but now that that's a bit retro many of
them end up here
in the tech tower here it's like someone
visited a few silicon valley startups
punched the copy button ran it through
google translate
and then hit paste in the middle of
siberia
here's the living wall only here it's
dead
here's the makerspace and the 3d printed
putin
here's the gym only it's siberia so it
comes with bear
hello innovation
case in point my new friend carrill
where are you from originally uh i was
born
here in academic was your father mother
engineers as well yeah yeah
they graduated from north civil state
university
and they was a computer engineer soviet
computer engineer with
big computers okay
you can tell by the terminator looking
device on the table
that karil makes drones he says his
drone is special
because it can take off vertically and
then fly very very far
very very fast thrill sees an optoplane
drone flying miles along high tension
power lines checking for breaks we're
zooming to the site of forest fires
and floods across siberia
a team of engineers barely out of high
school and most definitely still in
college
built this carbon fiber prototype by
hand in four months
it's quite a challenge to start a drone
startup
in russia because of low constraints
because of
investment climate traditions of of mind
of
our clients is not so easy to break
this is seen as sort of radical yeah
it's kind of radical technology
so this drone company started in a
russian government-funded incubator
is too radical for its clients who
maybe you guessed it or part of the
russian government
optoplane's first contract came from the
russian version of fema
and it built this first prototype with
money from a government-backed venture
capital firm
they wouldn't exist without the
government and they barely exist because
of it russia
is a very centralized country so
the united states for example with state
laws
is faster than in russia you have to get
exceptions
to test your drones and fly them around
here and that's difficult to do
yeah yeah so are there many drone
companies in russia
not so many as then in america
it looks really cool it looks good yeah
like uh
skynet
it's through the sheer force of their
engineering smarts and
passion that optoplane has gotten off
the ground
out here in siberia they're part of one
grand experiment
in state-supported innovation
we'll have to see what the next 60 years
bring to the silicon forest
up next on hello world i find myself at
a party for cyber cops
and hit the streets in moscow to shatter
what remains of your illusions
of personal privacy i would say that the
implications of this
very scary
there's never been a better time to take
in the epicness
of modern russia
the oil wealth that poured into the
country for a decade
has remade central moscow into a classy
european capital
only super-sized after all
this is the land of tchaikovsky and
pushkin tolstoy
and the bolshoi
now it's home to bohemian cocktail bars
and some of the best restaurants in the
world
the result is something intimidating
and well romantic
if you come from the west you can live
like an oligarch on the cheap
sanctions and low oil prices have cut
the ruble in half
doubling the fun for outsiders like me
but ask anyone here and they'll tell you
that the tensions with the west
won't diminish the russian soul
[Music]
russia's power comes from the force of
its intellect
and that's on display here at the
treichakov gallery
where the country's most iconic modern
artists hang from the walls
it got me thinking what is art really
an object an idea
a young expression of a super personal
alien impulse that creativity imposes on
its creator
oh this one's swirly
i wonder what this app does
this app gets five
stars for sure
it's called prisma and its creator
alexei moysenkov
uses machine learning magic to rebuild
your photos
into something that could hang in a
museum this painting is done by
alexander exter does it look like one of
your
filters yeah it's similar to a gothic
filter in our app
what would prisma pick up on yeah so for
example like
finding the right colors finding the
right shapes for example these circles
and then it will try to find the right
structure in your photo
and redraw it from scratch
prisma topped 2 million downloads a day
earlier this year
they program a vast network of computers
to study great artists
and then repaint your pictures from a
blank canvas
compared to that instagram filters are
weak sauce
they just tweak the color and exposure
of your photos
how do you train a neural net to do
something like that you you need only
one stylized picture
so you take like a picasso and then and
then a lot of a lot of a lot of
simple photos and then use picasso to
transfer that picasso style to these
details
these past few years russia has honed
the art of turning computer science
nerds
into ai building geniuses
to put another foot soldier in that ai
army to the test
i went right across the street from the
treichekov gallery
to one of moscow's spectacular public
spaces
gorky park just five years ago this was
a decaying soviet relic
today it's buzzing with people on wheels
and friendly russian faces
and my goal here is to find a few
hi would you mind if i take a photo of
your
face i'm trying to do a little bit of an
experiment can i take a photo of your
face
i just take a photo of you and then see
we see if it can find your vk
profile you might find me on facebook it
doesn't work on facebook yet because
they don't let you
search the database findface is an
android app that lets you take a picture
of a new friend
or a complete stranger in a few seconds
it scans all 250 million photos from vk
the russian facebook knockoff and then
finds a match
all right let's see what happens moment
of truth here we go
oh it's me oh it's me
yes yes it's me and your hair is so
different in the photo
definitely find me first yeah so it
works
yeah it's really cool do you think it's
strange
it's strange but cool you like some girl
and you take a photo
and you can find her and text her or
something yeah so you you guys like it i
wouldn't
like this so if i forgot
if this is my son or not i can be check
it
with my phone okay
this year fine face took its algorithm
to america
for something called the mega face
challenge
there it beat google and a lot of other
face spotting software
to find out how they did it nice to meet
you nice to meet you
i went to meet the algorithm's creator
at the office of his company
and tech do you mind showing me how the
technology works a little bit
yeah can we try me so these are my
russian brethren my cousins
is it ranked in order by who they think
looks the most
like yes this is like a 60 year old with
a machine gun
another guy with a gun i want to show
you something else
why am i a bear
so the similarity is very low but yes
algorithms that
there are some some similarity sometimes
it's difficult to
say why neural network works this way
but
but it works
arction programmed a neural network that
approaches face finding differently than
others
he fed it thousands of image matches and
after about six months of training
voila it learned to read faces
essentially you don't even know what the
neural network is
seeing in the beginning neural network
gives
random answers and the accuracy is close
to
zero and during training if everything
goes well the accuracy grows
and there are also neurons
some combinations of this neurons
responsible for
rays some combinations responsible for
type of eyes if you can efficiently
find the exact person among huge data
sets
it opens a lot more interesting use
cases
like for example you can search for
criminals in real life among
all the street cameras in the city
are we creeped out yet maybe we should
be
entech has already signed a contract
with the moscow city police
though archum won't talk about it and he
says they already have agreements with
other law enforcement agencies both
inside and outside russia
it's easy to imagine what the fbi or its
russian counterpart the fsb
could do with this kind of technology so
it's a little bit controversial right
because
anyone can identify you now out of the
crowd i would say that the implications
of this
very scary i think f is
searching us right there i'm companies
here are big companies corporations and
governments definitely know everything
about you but
for random people this makes it much
easier
you have to be careful if you go it
outside in the street or in the facebook
or any other social network you've done
it
you're open to to be recognized
[Music]
this idea that you're not anonymous when
you walk the street anymore somebody can
just snap your photo
and identify who you are you must have
thought about that when you were
developing
the technology when we were developing
we were thinking only about accuracy and
how cool it is but apply washi finish
when you have
smartphones with you because they can
track all the information about you
it's a battle between technology and
privacy
[Music]
my personal guess that technology will
win
[Music]
on the outskirts of moscow you'll find
skokama
this is the mothership of
state-sponsored innovation
the kremlin is coaxing companies and
workers here
with promises of government support
i came here to take in its hugeness and
to meet one of skokova's rising stars a
criminologist
named ilya sachikov hello ilya
hi how are you i'm good nice to see you
nice to see you yeah
illya heads group ib a private company
based in moscow
that tries to find ever elusive russian
hackers
unmask them and then hand them over to
the authorities
we something like the superheroes
in our field we help our clients to
solve
very very difficult cases we use the
branding like fbi look at your picture
man you look like james bond
this is photoshop
group ib specializes in investigating
fraud and theft
the type of stuff that makes up 99 of
cyber crime
people look on the cyber crime like an
iceberg they could see only the
upper thing but underwater a lot of
infrastructure a lot of
politicians a lot of corrupt people from
the different organization
and this is the future they walk a
tightrope
cooperating with russian law enforcement
while also serving major international
clients
like citibank and microsoft
you have foreign clients today huge
companies but as the tensions between
china and the us and russia they just
seem to be escalating especially when it
comes
to cyber security actually we had office
in new york
it was really funny experience because
every week we have
had excursion from phoebi from the new
york police
they ask what are you doing here it just
seems like that will make it so much
harder for you guys to expand
your business i think with our knowledge
that we really have good understanding
of russian cyber crime
so i think this is competitive advantage
but do you think
with the tensions between the us and
russia right now that russia would be
upset if you had an office
in silicon valley i think yes we have
some
toxic knowledge about the organized
crime and cyber crime and
i think it's not a government it's some
people in government
private companies without any control do
investigations
get some knowledge of course they are
not happy
[Music]
you think of hackers as these guys
sitting in their basement with their
hats and their hoodies on
well this is what the people look like
who hunt them this is russia's
largest cyber crime event
recognition competition by google
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
in college with a few buddies one of
them is dimitri volkov
the company's head hacker hunter
[Music]
uh
attacking
i visited group ib's moscow office to
find out more about how dimitri chases
cyber criminals
is the russian hacking community is that
the the biggest
cyber crime community in the world we're
different so
russian speaking hack is so famous
because we share knowledge we
development tools we share
information about how to attack banks
how security measures applied on
different systems
so a huge amount of information is
available on the ground community
what's the art of that and the technique
main goal is to get the full history of
hacker's activity because
when hacker starts he do a lot of
mistakes
we have more than one hundred thousand
profiles about
hackers who communicated on the
russian-speaking underground community
this is fully automated we have
artificial intelligence
implementing the security solutions we
have special algorithms to detect
unknown programs
and it's always interesting to see and
of course to track
how khakis are good operate techniques
and tools to
do attacks what does
a russian hacker look like who are these
people if he's
an attacker who is doing just technical
job usually he
lives alone but if we talk about
organizers of affordable schemes
usually these people are very rich
we don't wear hoods where you're driving
good cars living in good houses
have very beautiful women i can say it's
like a muffin
[Music]
group ib now occupies an uncomfortable
position
at the intersection of cold war
geopolitics and organized crime
like the mafia from russia's unruly
caucuses
during an early group ib investigation
ilia learned that one of their targets
had ordered the mobsters to kill him if
you know about the
kafkas and organized group it's not
funny at all and do you have bodyguards
i had bodyguards for two years but i
didn't i understand if someone would
like to do something bad
they will do
[Music]
[Music]
peace on cyber earth may come but just
in case
russia is building a series of startup
cities to increase the might and reach
of its sovereign tech
to an outsider like me the depth of
russia's state influence on companies
feels flat out backward and wrong it's
hard to imagine a true tech utopia
springing up in a place like this edward
snowden
yes he's somewhere out there
would say the u.s has its eyes
everywhere too
whether you're on this internet or that
one
you're never alone anymore
[Music]
up next on hello world i travel to
chile's atacama desert
to go hunting for the origins of the
universe
and find myself with the help of a
shaman
and some low-tech frog poison
[Music]
you